and now the linesman got taken out by Ryan
MCD and MCD had to give up the puck awkward
play thrown back to the net and a great save by
Soros the outlet pass stolen by Dylan strong it
comes back around oetkin fell down Parson with
Evangelista and now the pass over hits an open
man carrier and a good save by Charlie lingren
and lingren has been big part of the story you
saw his numbers there really really good year
for him so far done a TS in the goalie pu loose
kick towards the stick by sistens but he
couldn't come up with it off the crossbar
last night he is a shoo machine right now he's
got to get one to go watch the net front Tren
andol be in front linger this goes under his
P trying to wrestle it free from Van reight
he finds his man shot by thomasino was block
did not get on net thomasino retrieving Luke
Shen a bomb stretching save by Ling run
diving for for the rebound is Cole Smith
sticks are flying in the craziness Tyson Barry
working with Shen tried to feed it back Barry
with a big goal last night refound try by Cole
Smith is stop the capitals were five for five
in their gain in Philadelphia the other night
caps 12 overall at 81% here is Yosi tip they
score Colton cens at the net front with another
expert tip and the Predators have taken a one-
nothing lead on a power play goal well Colton
sistens in his 31st game play this season is going
to get his 10th goal of the season right in front
of the net look at the effort to get that puck
back and sistence goes right to the middle this is
a high tip and a perfect shot by Yosi to get this
tip he's not shooting a score he's shooting for
that tip and Colton assistence comes in perfectly
look at that that is absolutely beautiful tips
it back against the grain past lingren for the
beautiful power play goal in the second period as
was down 42 and 53 but changes hands of Angelisa
give it go right in front great save by lingren he
was under siege watch this look at this play right
here this little crafty little play nov back
to nov back and now a drive by Evangel saved
by lingren Nashville in a line change Here Comes
Cole Smith on the scene he steals it away right
in front up top backand save this is it one on
two behind the net Smith comes out with the puck
gets in a good score here doesn't quite get all
of it and Bruno wants him moving the puck to the
forwards and then joining the rush leag but he's
got it going on now rebound and great save on the
second attempt by SOS still a broken stick on the
ice MC Mel quick move and tight quarter scored a
goal in Philadelphia on a similar play poris looks
to the slot it's deflected by Kier Kier trying to
get it back generate more off the rush they taken
a little bit of a step back in that department
there protus Bo he's got the reach loose puck
right in front looking forward and finding it
this Soros oi got slammed into the corner another
penalty fall is coming up on Nashville loose
behind the net and Wilson bangs into Shen Shen
and Wilson eyeing each other up close now over
to ketov ketov back to Carlson now oetkin save
Soros no rebound to be read perfectly by SOS
watch how aggressive he gets on that pass up top
we know what going oetkin right we know it's going
to number eight eventually going to go back up and
watch Saros on this play right there boom he comes
up right into the midsection that was beautiful
94 milph on the shot by oetkin here he is again
oetkin tees it up right in front tip what a save
by S and it goes by him it's in the net and what
a save and oi gets it on the back door Rebound
ohin with the shot pass that time Oshi got the
tip yeah let's see who got that that was tipped
in front there by strowman it looks like Oshi
comes from the side of the net look it's just get
a squeak by and then Oshi comes in and gets that
puck in and oetkin Nice Shot pass there to stro
and then yeah oh she's going to get that one no
chance for juice on a first beautiful save I'm not
sure that dropped on that 7 seconds left on that
Smith penalty now to Nets off able to get it to
avkin another bomb SOS falling back as he makes
another save on the onetime out of the box comes
mcdunn competitors get out of it and now they've
got the puck oil off to Yosi rebound bouncing
in the slot Here Comes St s in front and Barry
t tied up the stick nicely now Nashville still
in trouble shoulder save by Soros on Wilson to
the middle farar looking up the ice he'll put it
in gear farari and a lunging save by sarus thrown
back behind the net comes Nashville across the
line four on three if they hurry Nyquist looking
at Barry as the trailer line change coming on
no back just into the game a bomb by Terrier
thrusting out with the left leg was lingren Novak
playing without a stick right now stro cross ice
what a save oetkin with the Pat in one Tim shut
down and now that one off the bar crossy feed
back checking is Smith flicks it ahead and now a
chance kamino on the Breakaway Phil kamino he's
SC oh what a turn of the V Phil thomasino
Nashville was under all kinds of pressure
and thomasino delivers it for a 2-1 lead 7
minutes and 53 seconds without a whistle and
then thomasino as the predators of it under
siege it felt like the whole time watch this
little play there right to the middle of the
ice and thomasino pump fake forehand backhand
beats lingren to give the Predators the lead
on just an unbelievable sequence of events
there send the next five on five unit
on Q here for the final seconds as mace
predicted and out of the box carry feeds
it to the front he went into the than
goore yov Tren he got it caught in his skates he
found it in time and the Predators right after
the power play expires have thrown the lead
to 31 they didn't get much on the power play
but after look at the relentlessness there Yakov
trenin he was on the boards put that puck around
goes to the net gets it with the skate right here
stops it stays with it one hand and to the people
goes the yak this is Dylan stro he'll work his
way down Wilson got dumped in oon shot a diving
block by Lozan sent back in front nice stick
there by car that'll send them back St next pass
read well by siss he's got the steal siss to the
slot McCarron up back caner back to the forehand
scramble in front of the blue ice s just wide in
the neutral zone right there not he's complaining
about that he was still complaining after this
sequence right there and then oh McCarron does
he goes into lingren that's close cuz he didn't
get pushed in great there uh so that's in tight
quarters behind the n Smith comes away with
it Smith has assists in the last three he hits
marcaron and a great Club savear has an assist
tonight as well this fourth line has been very
good now it's thomasino he's got a goal tonight
finds Cole Smith head back across the line but
Nashville will keep those seconds turning off the
clock they catch him in a line change mccaran eyes
the net rebound right in front po Smith thought he
might have tucked it behind him on the second try
Novak got a play from the side of there 4 seconds
to go Novak shot off the glove of lingren final
seconds ticking down that is going to do it no
back dumped to the ice after he put it in the net